Gregory generate reasons to GRE
Instagram Twitter how getting that by
the way at the beginning facebook.com
slash bloom house in the real rejects
social media manager that sick of saying
that at the end of every video with you
do sorry alright Aldo Jones he hit us up
on her Facebook this morning and I was
like we got a message from Aldo Jones
what does my yes he did a new video and
he specifically requested that we watch
this video yeah yeah so we got
permission miss you got permission
what's it called when you dance in every
movie with Bruce Wayne interesting this
is more than just a trailer parody
apparently how do Jones Branch now
oh that's cool he's got even white yeah
he's gonna like take it out
whoa it's gonna be than you've been
having me really do sigourney weaver's
really oh [__] oh really what's the next
one okay let's try to do this job
alright alright alright
Justice League is the first one
I don't want them sir
Star Wars Jurassic world the lost world
three jobs never a sharknado sharknado
near dine in Paris
North by Northwest Road Point Break
predator predator predator 2 in la fried
nurse and brightener Mulan Toy Story
castaway huh
Curious Case of Benjamin Button Superman
for the quest for peace Leonard at the
eight lemonade's that's that's my
favorite one The Godfather by the two
rear window through a window a
wheelchair
yeah oh oh we already cook it up
swagger man Sam Raimi Terminator 2
Judgment Day yeah opening credits
oh here a lot magneto okay yeah
ghostbusters 2016 yes
well that family guy episode would
Stewie yeah totally
that's one and that is the tech
amendments right there totally
we did it although John we did it we
named a moment oh and the Last Samurai
great now we should get mentioning your
next weird trailer yeah we named all the
malls all the films 100% accurate with
only a couple anomalies at the very big
and there's only like one or two wheel I
just didn't spit out fast enough but
other than that we got we got that we
basically we proved our moving all the
group right here in this video that's my
baby a real rejects Aldo
that's why cuz we're not fake reject I
hope you mentioned us I hope you mention
us and if you don't if you don't we'll
find out during that reaction in that
reaction although bones my name is
lieutenant aldo how'd those scones
aldose come a steamed ons call him up
aldo hones in on the edit he does he
does all those stones i'll do me the we
decorate for you dude hey it would be a
weird honor to have a strain named after
you Aldo Aldo clones as I fine loans
himself then we would have so many weird
trailers Aldo known she's like really
smart tones
you know how though tones different tone
tone or the muscles color different
shades we've contributed to your video
alright that's fine that's a good size
subscribe to the real rejects to set all
John [__] at the beginning of the video
subscribe to Aldo Jones the link to this
video is in the description box make
sure to go and watch the actual video
get him his view
I'm sure with the song used in this
video that his video is definitely
monetized deaf meaning our video is
definitely monetized to all that we're
both making so much money right now off
of all the views at all money with this
royalty-free soundtrack